let this be a lesson to toddlers
everywhere you tiny little
three-year-olds and four-year-olds won't
be spreading your bigotry and
intolerance in the state-run British
nurseries anymore got it if your
three-year-old pal Oliver shows up to
the sandbox one day and tells you that
his new name is Olivia you better not be
confused by her new pronouns because if
you are confused by Zur pronouns Z can
report you to the nurse who will spend
you and send you home to
Mommy then Mommy will have to take a few
days off from her job at the bigot
Factory to watch you herself and she
deserves it for filling your racist
little head with the idea that toddlers
shouldn't be punished for being confused
when they don't understand something
Newsweek reports a British nursery's
decision to suspend a toddler for abuse
against sexual orientation and gender
identity has triggered widespread
backlash prompting political statements
and online debate about disciplinary
policies in early childhood education
the unnamed child aged three or four was
suspended from a state Nursery during
the 2022 to 2023 Academic Year according
to data from the United Kingdom's
department for Education obtained by the
telegraph why would there be a backlash
against punishing an intolerant
toddler what's the alternative not
punishing him how would he then learn
not to question the ideology you're
imposing on
him new figures from the Department for
re-education show that school exclusions
for transphobic or homophobic Behavior
Rose from 164 in 2021 to 2022 to 178 in
2022 to
2023 during the same period 94 children
in state primary schol schools were
either suspended or permanently excluded
for alleged transphobic or homophobic
Behavior including 13 pupils as young as
four or five the disclosure has
triggered backlash on social media
mainly from critics of transgender
activism former NCAA swimmer and women's
sports Advocate Riley Gaines wrote on X
formerly Twitter a 4-year-old boy in the
UK was suspended from his Nursery School
forain trans phobia yes you read that
right we have reached Peak clown world
the only clowns here Riley gains are
people who think biological men
shouldn't be humiliating biological
women in race after race after race
think about it if biological men don't
keep biological women from winning first
place at every swim competition who will
so if you have a problem with biological
women being permanently excluded from
winning the top spots in women's sports
why don't you biological women just go
and form your own swim
league author JK Rowling called the
suspension totalitarian insanity and
wrote If you think small children should
be punished for being able to recognize
sex you're a dangerous Zealot who should
be nowhere near kids or in any position
of authority over them sounds like JK
Rowling and the intolerant toddler need
to spend a few years in aaban so they
can learn that questioning dangerous
zealots is no longer tolerated in muggle
World British prime minister Kier
starmer distanced himself from the
incident a spokesperson for starmer told
the telegraph obviously the Prime
Minister would not support those sorts
of measures while noting the specifics
of the incident remain
undisclosed pupils and staff should
never be subject to abuse but any action
taken to tackle Behavior should also be
proportionate the spokesperson said
beyond commentary the department for
indoctrination said it expects schools
to act decisively but fairly thank you
to tier Kier starmer for pointing out
that punishments should be
proportionate of course if some
80-year-old man deserves prison for
complaining about the grooming gangs on
Facebook I don't know why a
four-year-old shouldn't be punished for
using the wrong pronouns at the
nursery however for many the most
troubling part of the case is its lack
of
transparency no details have been
provided about what the child allegedly
said or did leaving observers to
question whether any genuine harm was
done or whether disciplinary policies
have crossed into absurd
territory this should be obvious by now
but if people find out about the tactics
you're using to brainwash their children
they tend to get upset so it's best to
keep the reprogramming and the
experiments you're performing a total
secret people can't get mad if they have
no clue what's happening Lord young
director of the Free Speech Union a
non-governmental organization told the
telegraph it Beggars belief that schools
are suspending children as young as five
for breaching their transphobia policy
if your ideology is so rigid it
justifies you punishing toddlers for not
complying with it that's a powerful
argument for discarding it get your
facts right Lord young it's not children
as young as five it's children as young
as three to
four why didn't you learn to count get
kicked out of the nursery
perhaps a department for Education
spokesperson told the independent all
pupils and staff should feel safe and
protected at school and should never
face violence or
abuse yes the best way to make a toddler
feel safe is to kick him out of the
nursery for using the wrong
pronouns the surge in disciplinary
actions for transphobia comes amid
broader concerns about school Behavior
post pandemic according to the
department for brainwashing and child
experimentation more than 787 th000
pupils were suspended in 2022 to 2023
more than double the number from 2016 to
2017 of these
84339 were Primary School students up
31% from the previous year it's weird
you'd think that students who went
through the pandemic would have learned
not to question anything the government
tells them but no here they are
resisting their government
programming why do Educators need to
condition people when they're
young well there's a glaring hypocrisy
at the core of this movement and kids
need to be trained either not to notice
it or at the very least not to mention
it it is the hypocrisy that must not be
named watch how easy it is to
spot a very small percentage of people
grow up with gender dysphoria biological
boys feel like they're girls biological
girls feel like they're boys the
percentages vary from place to place and
from time to time but the overall
numbers when the dsm5 came out were
extremely low according to the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders fifth edition gender
dysphoria prevalence accounts for
0.005 to
0.014% of the population for biological
males and 0
002 to
0.003% for biological
females so naturally occurring gender
dysphoria is very very rare should you
be angry or upset at someone who has
gender dysphoria of course not they
didn't decide to have gender dysphoria
so why would you blame or hate them but
suppose someone says we should find all
the students who have gender dysphoria
and condition them to behave in line
with their biological sex not with how
they feel in other words suppose someone
says if a boy feels like a girl we will
condition him to act like a boy anyway
and if a girl feels like a boy we will
condition her to act like a girl
anyway how would that message be
received people would say how dare you
condition a child to feel like a gender
different from the one he he or she
feels like naturally if a boy feels like
a girl you have no right to change that
through
conditioning and if a girl feels like a
boy you have no right to change that
through conditioning you have to let
children just be themselves without you
or anyone else influencing them on
issues like
gender that's the rule right you
shouldn't be pressuring kids to go
against the way they feel so what's the
problem well I mentioned that naturally
occurring gender dysphoria affects a
tiny percentage of the population yet
the number of kids identifying as trans
has been
skyrocketing Hollywood celebrities can
proudly say that all the kids they know
are
trans I am here today as the mother of a
proud trans
man I am here today as the aunt of of a
man my best friend's kid is trans and my
kids's best friend is
trans my wife and I our lives are filled
with the most amazing beautiful Brave
trans people young and old but
especially young now if gender dysphoria
affects a tiny tiny percentage of
children what are the odds that that
every other Hollywood celebrity has a
trans kid or has adopted a kid who soon
transitioned it's mathematically absurd
to think that all or most or even a
significant portion of these kids were
born with gender dysphoria which
strongly suggests that the grown-ups
around them are putting the idea into
their
heads but what does that
mean it means that adults are
conditioning children who don't
naturally feel like they were assigned
the wrong gender to feel like they were
assigned the wrong
gender they're taking kids who don't
feel like they're trapped in the wrong
body and programming them to feel like
they're trapped in the wrong
body why would they do that because in
Hollywood having a trans kid is a far
greater status symbol than having a
designer bag or a designer dress or even
an Oscar and it's not just Hollywood
schools are filled with trans kids far
beyond the standard
percentages so adults are massively
influencing the gender feelings of
children they're conditioning kids to
feel a certain way when those kids
wouldn't have felt that way apart from
the
conditioning but wasn't that the
cardinal sin according to the trans
movement wasn't the main rule that you
shouldn't pressure or influence a
child's feelings about gender
and yet it's exactly what the champions
of the movement are
doing this is the glaring hypocrisy I
mentioned if a child feels like he or
she is a different gender you must not
under any circumstances pressure that
child not to feel that way but if a
child doesn't feel like he or she is a
different gender it's perfectly
acceptable to pressure that child to
feel like he or she is a different
gender she hypocrisy that even a child
could spot and that's why the British
government has learned to start
punishing kids while they're young no
one should be allowed to question the
latest ideology of the latest
government least of all toddlers
[Music]